this morning more people in washington
say supreme court justice clarence
thomas should remove himself from cases
related to the 2020 election his wife
conservative activist jenny thomas sent
text messages to then white house chief
of staff mark meadows backing the effort
to overturn the election cbs news and
the washington post revealed more than
two dozen of those texts last week chief
election and campaign correspondent
robert costa broke the story robert good
morning tell us what's the latest good
morning cbs news has learned the house
committee investigating the deadly
january 6 attack is considering
questioning justice thomas's wife or
inviting her to voluntarily appear among
the 29 messages between ginny thomas and
mark meadows were ones like this message
for trump from november do not concede
it takes time for the army who is
gathering for his back in response a
growing number of democrats are calling
on justice thomas to recuse himself from
2020 election-related cases senator amy
klobuchar who sits on the judiciary
committee said over the weekend that the
entire integrity of the court is on the
line and joined other democrats in
calling for ethics rules for the supreme
court the nine justices are the only u.s
judges not governed by an official code
of ethical conduct gop lawmakers have
defended thomas saying they have full
confidence in him
meanwhile cbs news has learned that
several of the house committee members
believe major gaps exist in the records
meadows has shared one republican member
adam kinzinger told cbs news yesterday
that he's not confident that meadows has
handed over all of his text messages
the committee will meet later today to
vote on contempt of congress charges for
former white house officials peter
navarro and dan scovino now navarro is a
key figure who the committee alleges
worked with former white house
strategist steve bannon on efforts to
delay the certification of the election
and scovino he was one of trump's
closest confidants inside the west wing
statements from scovino and navarro
claim executive privilege prohibits them
from providing testimony
vlad wow
bob as always comprehensive reporting
thank you very much